president biden terms those who want to
reopen society
neanderthals ebay stops people from
buying dr seuss books
and we examine the radicalism of the
democrats new voter registration law hr1
i'm ben shapiro this is the ben shapiro
show
the ben shapiro show is sponsored by
expressvpn why haven't you gotten a vpn
yet visit expressvpn.com
ben alrighty so we begin with a
perfectly obvious
truism at this point joe biden is not in
control of his own administration this
is not a person who is sentient he's not
a person who is with it joe biden
always was a trojan horse and democrats
are not really making a lot of bones
about this at this point
they're pretty obvious about the fact
that joe biden is just a moderate face
for radical policy
in fact nancy pelosi said this out loud
just yesterday
she was doing a presser with the white
house and this is the same presser where
joe biden
basically said i'm ready to take
questions and then the person behind the
camera just kind of
slowly faded well nancy pelosi was
talking about joe biden
and she explained what joe biden is he
is just an instrument he's an instrument
of power for these folks because joe
biden is not with it
nor was joe biden ever quite as moderate
as everybody liked to make him out to be
just because you're moderate compared to
bernie sanders does not mean
that you are in fact moderate so here is
nancy pelosi
at whitehouse.gov explaining that joe
biden is basically just a gumball
machine
right you throw your you throw your
liberal quarter in there and out comes
the gumball
in order to open these doors we do not
say
open sesame we say open
biden that's our magic word
open fighting i love it
what is wrong with that person i mean my
goodness
she's she's like a bond villain nancy
pelosi but
she is not wrong right that is the way
that the left views joe biden that's the
media view joe biden joe biden was
always a trojan horse for these policies
some of us were warning people of this
beforehand
and make no mistake the radicals are
celebrating this ezra klein
the newest opinion columnist over at the
new york times he has a piece called
biden is the anti-trump and it's working
if you dial down the conflict you can
dial up the policy
because all of america is now about
optics so if joe biden appears to be
moderate then he can push some of the
most radical policy changes that we have
seen in our lifetimes
according to ezra klein american
politics feels quieter with joe biden in
the white house the president's twitter
feed hasn't gone dark but it's gone dull
biden doesn't pick needless fights or
insert himself into the cultural
conflicts it's easy to go days without
hearing anything the president has said
unless you go looking well right because
he's not actually alive
he's just a house plant sitting in the
corner that they bring out every so
often look at the pretty house plant and
then meanwhile in the background they're
like what if we push this particular
radical policy
the relative quiet is deceptive says as
recline policy is moving at breakneck
pace
the first week of the biden
administration were consumed by a flurry
of far-reaching executive orders that
reopened america to refugees rejoined
the paris climate accordance and killed
the keystone xl oil pipeline to name
just a few now the house has passed and
the senate is considering the 1.9
trillion
american rescue plan a truly sweeping a
truly sweeping piece of legislation that
includes more than a half dozen policies
like a child tax credit expansion
that could cut child poverty by 50 that
would be presidency defining
accomplishments
on their own it goes on the white house
just sent congress the most ambitious
immigration reform bill
in years it midwifed a deal to get merck
to mobilize some of its factories to
produce johnson and johnson vaccine and
now biden is saying there should be
enough of a supply for every american
adult to get vaccinated by the end of
may
imagine the administration is also
working on an infrastructure package
that if early reports bear out will be
the most transformational piece of
climate policy and perhaps economic
policy
in my lifetime biden is blitzing okay so
a couple of things one if donald trump
had been soft-spoken
i really really doubt that the media
would have suggested that his policies
were better than they were right the the
fact is that the media hated trump's
policy and so they also hated his
personality it's not really the other
way around remember donald trump was a
favorite among the
left-wing glitterati until he declared
himself a republican at which point he
became the enemy now trump didn't do
himself any favors by shooting himself
in the foot a lot
but that is not the same thing as what
is happening here what is happening here
is that joe biden is saying ridiculous
things on a daily basis
and yet everybody continues to cover for
him because he's a democrat
it is that simple joe biden has not
returned a sense of normalcy to the
white house he's returned a sense of
senility to the white house and
the radical policy that the media loves
and make no mistake this is radical
policy
it is deeply radical policy so for
example democrats have been pushing
forward
hr1 now you haven't heard a lot about hr
1 because hr 1 is not going anywhere in
the senate presumably but
hr 1 is this sweeping piece of voter
legislation that essentially federalizes
all elections
and what it really does is it makes it
easier to enshrine the worst sort of
voting practices from across the country
it takes like all the worst parts of
voting practice from various states
and then it enshrines them and requires
them at the federal level heritage
foundation had a good breakdown
of hr1 here are just some of the things
that hr 1 would do
according to the heritage foundation hr
1 would seize the authority of states to
regulate
voter registration and the voting
process forcing states to implement
early voting automatic voter
registration same day registration
online voter registration and no fault
absentee balloting right so the
universal mail in balloting
that is a rich mine to vain
for a rich vain to mine for for all the
people who would love ballot harvesting
and
and would love to be able to game the
system that would become universal
and by the way it would also make it
pretty much mandatory that elections
would go on for weeks at a time because
these absentee ballots take a while
to count so whatever faithful fate in
elections still remains would quickly be
lost with hr1 but
of course that doesn't matter to the
democrats hr one would make it easier to
commit fraud and promote cass at the
polls through same-day registration
literally you would walk up
and you would cast a provisional ballot
and you register at the exact same time
it takes a little while to process all
of that
and makes it kind of easy to confuse the
system
hr one would mandate 15 days of early
voting which diffuses the intensity of
get out the vote efforts i am very much
against
early voting unless you have an actual
medical reason you cannot vote or
you cannot vote on the day of it is
called election day not election months
hr 1 would degrade the accuracy of
registration list it would require
states to automatically register all
individuals not even citizens right
illegal immigrants
from state and federal databases this
would register large numbers of elite of
ineligible voters
hr one would open the door for hackers
and cyber criminals to commit massive
voter registration fraud
through online voter registration that
is not tied to an existing state record
like a driver's license
hr one would make it a criminal offense
for a state official to reject a voter
registration application
even when it is rejected under color of
law because the individual
because the official believes the
individual is ineligible to vote
hr1 would require states to allow 16 and
17 year olds to register
would effectively ensure that if you're
underage you could then
vote also by the way hr 1 gets rid of
penalties
for voting mistakenly or supposedly
mistakenly or fraudulently hr one would
require states to count ballots cast by
voters
outside of their outside priests and
they're assigned to precincts overriding
the precinct system used by almost all
states that allows election officials to
monitor votes staff polling places
provide enough ballots
and prevent election fraud
hr 1 would ban witness signature or
notarization requirements for absentee
ballots it would force states to accept
absentee ballots received up to 10 days
after election day
as long as they are postmarked by
election day what if they're not
postmarked
right this is the big controversy over
in pennsylvania this last time around
h.r 1 would prevent election officials
from checking the eligibility and
qualifications of voters
and removing ineligible voters it would
ban state voter id laws you would not be
allowed to check somebody's id at the
polling places
voter intimidation or coercion that
prevents someone from registering or
voting is already a federal crime but hr
one would add a provision that
criminalizing
hindering interfering or preventing
anyone from registering or voting which
is so broad and vague that it could
prevent
providing any information to election
officials about ineligibility
such as an applicant not being a u.s
citizen would be banned
right there's all sorts of other
problems with hr1 it is a truly radical
piece
of legislation it would make it a
violation of federal law to engage in
quote-unquote partisan redistricting
it would mandate the inclusion of alien
population both legal and illegal
in all redistricting in other words it
would basically
radically change the voting system of
the united states it would not be status
quo 2020 would be much worse than that
it essentially legalizes ballot
harvesting which i think is truly
corrupt right ballot harvesting is the
practice
whereby you just go door to door with a
democratic list and you only pick up
their ballot
and then republicans only send out their
people to pick up the ballots
right this is a pretty good way of
ensuring that it is not about who casts
the ballots it's about who collects the
ballots
it's a serious problem hr one okay and
this is being pushed forward and the
media love it and the idea is if you
oppose hr one
this is because you are some sort of
vicious racist who doesn't want
everybody to vote
everybody who's eligible should vote and
they should do all the things they ought
to do in order to vote but if you're too
stupid to figure out how to register to
vote or if you don't feel like going
down to the
ballot box to vote on election day this
is your problem frankly i am not
i am not against the idea that it ought
to take a little more effort
than simply clicking a box in order for
you to vote
because guess what voting is not just a
right it is also a privilege it is both
it is both you have a right to vote but
it is a privilege for you to be able to
take part in our electoral system and if
you choose not to do that
because you don't feel like following
the steps that one's on you
i mean frankly if you can't follow the
voting procedures it's very easy to vote
in the united states it truly is
then i'm not sure that you should be
voting if you literally cannot do it
right if you have some sort of inability
that makes you unable to do it that is
one thing but if you're a normal citizen
and you just didn't do the steps
your fault okay in any case all this is
being pushed forward
by the biden administration and again
this is considered
perfectly fine because joe biden it's
open biden right so long as biden is
that this is the problem for democrats
if biden were to plot
if something were to happen to biden god
forbid and kamala here kamala harris
were to become president
she doesn't have a moderate mean she is
not a person who people see as moderate
it would actually stymie their agenda in
a lot of ways
the media by the way are are doing all
of biden's heavy lifting for him
we'll get to this in just one moment
first let us talk about a truly
meaningful thing
that you can do for your friends for
your family for yourself i'm talking
about a wonderful
beautiful painted portrait of yourself
your family
a place it's something that's meaningful
to you now that stuff sounds
like it's going to be really onerous and
really burdensome and really expensive
right
yeah you think of the old-fashioned
portrait painting where you'd have to
sit there for
eight hours while somebody painted a
portrait of you or something or it's
gonna cost a fortune because you have to
find an artist of him thousands of
dollars
not anymore this is why you have to try
paintyourlife.com and get a professional
hand-painted portrait created from any
photo
at a truly affordable price choose from
a team of world-class artists and work
with them
until every detail is perfect they've
got a user-friendly platform that lets
you order a custom-made hand-painted
portrait in less than five minutes it's
a quick and easy process
get a hand-painted portrait in about
three weeks send any picture
yourself kids family special place pet
or combine photos into one painting so
if somebody's not even there
they can be part of your portrait as
well it's amazing we have one hanging
over our couch at home
it's a picture of me and my wife and two
of our kids we need to get a new one
because we got a new baby at
paintyourlife.com there is no risk
if you don't love the final painting
your money is refunded
guaranteed and right now is a limited
time offer get 20 off your painting
that's right 20
off and free shipping to get the special
offer text the word ben to 64 000 that
is ben
do 64 000 text my name ben 64 000
paint your life celebrate the moments
that matter most terms apply available
at painterlife.com
terms again text 000. okay so
meanwhile the media continued to provide
cover for all of these radical plans
philip bump who's just awful over at the
washington post this is
one of the most bizarre and overtly
partisan pieces i have ever seen he
wrote a piece it is titled while the
senate read the coronavirus relief bill
nearly 900 americans may have died from
the virus originally it said 1400
americans now because fewer americans
are dying
of covet he had to downgrade it to 900.
okay so
his take is that the problem here is
that the coveted relief bill needs to be
rushed through
senator ron johnson and a bunch of other
republicans have
held off on the process because they
said you know we need you to read this
it's a 700 page bill 628 pages
we need you to actually read it because
we're not going to pass a 1.9 trillion
dollar spending bill
without anybody having read the thing
and this column is phillip bump he's
like you know what
if you read the bill people will die we
have now reached the point in american
politics where if you read the bill
people will die is considered a good
point
remember nancy pelosi held up code
relief for six months
they held up covered relief all the way
through the election
and the idea was that politics required
that she hold up the coveted relief and
by the way
kovit was much worse in october november
december than it is right now
right now thank god covet has waned in
the united states we're at about 40 000
new cases
every single day in the united states we
are down dramatically in terms of the
number of deaths we're seeing every day
across the country
we'll get to that in a second because
the democrats refuse to accept that of
course
but the idea is if you even read the
bill people are dying
this is how biased or idiotic media are
philip bump of the washington post if
you read the bill people will die oh
really how are those months where we
didn't pass the bill how did that go
says phillip bump at this moment on this
issue time
can be measured in human lives on
average nearly 2 000 people a day are
dying from covenant 19 the disease
caused by the virus that's a death about
once every 44 seconds
it's an improvement over the end of
january but it's still a far faster rate
than the country had seen
for much of the pandemic cbs's frank
thorpe reported the reading of the bill
began at about 3 22 p.m by 401 the
reader had gotten only to page 40 a rate
of about 37 pages an hour the bill is
628 pages long so
if the text of the bill were
consistently dense throughout it would
have taken about 17 hours to read it
reading it would end about 8 am on
friday the readers did pick up the pace
the reading of the bill completed after
10 hours 44 minutes given the current
rate at which people are dying of covid
that means about 880 americans likely
succumbed
to the disease during that period now
this is a particularly stupid point
because you know what would have
happened to those people if um they not
read the bill they would have died
these two things are utterly
disassociated there's no connection
between reading the bill and people
dying
and bump acknowledges that she says it's
not the case those lives have been saved
had the bill passed sooner but it is the
case that more immediate assistance for
things like vaccines or bolstering
people's bank accounts is better than
slower relief so then why are you
connecting the two things if they're
irrelevant because again
all of politics is just about taking
advantage of
a particular crisis or as the case may
be ignoring a crisis down at the border
we are saying
thousands of children arrive every month
unaccompanied minors arriving every
single month
we don't have the space to house them
they've been re-erecting
all of the evil trump-era cages and
tents
and yet because the democrats don't want
it to be a crisis it's not a crisis
here's jen sackey once again saying it
is not a crisis at the border even
though it's pretty obviously a crisis at
the border
does that mean that you consider it an
actual genuine emergency
well i would say that that's probably a
question for the department of homeland
security uh who obviously oversees that
and the department of home health and
human services who oversees the
facilities and the shelters where
these kids are um certainly one of our
concerns
is that um there are there is a you know
as
we were talking about earlier an influx
of kids at
a rate in a pace um that uh is going to
require us
to uh you know make considerations about
where we're going to safely
house them well i mean is it a crisis i
guess it's not a crisis
of course it's not a crisis because if
you were declared a crisis you might
actually have to do something about it
alejandro mayorkas who's the head of the
department of homeland security says the
same thing well it's a challenge
not a crisis it's a challenge see kovid
which is now on the wane
is a crisis requiring us to blow out the
spending to the tune of twice
the actual amount sorry four times the
amount of actual damage done to the
economy in the year 2021 by cobia 19.
and we know that the shortfall is going
to be about 400 billion dollars 450
billion dollars this year
in terms of cover 19 doing damage to the
american gdp we are about to blow out
the spending to the tune of 1.9 trillion
and inflate the currency to boot but
that's because we have a crisis of
course but when we have thousands of
unaccompanied minors showing up the
border and no way to deal with them
that's just a challenge because we don't
actually want to do anything about it
here's alejandro mayorkas
what we are doing is building the
capacity to address the needs of those
children
and we are guided by uh some core
principles
number one we act in the best interest
of the children and we act in the best
interest of the american people
and thirdly we adhere to our values and
principles
as a country and so in fact the numbers
are significant
the challenge is significant uh and our
plans
are well underway as we build the
capacity to address
the needs of the children and we are
rebuilding from scratch
nope nope here's what's actually
happening according to the washington
post the biden administration is
preparing to convert its immigrant
family detention centers in south texas
into ellis island-style rapid processing
hubs that will screen migrant parents
and children with the goal of releasing
them into the united states within 72
hours
okay so their solution is not to hold
people until we know whether they ought
to be here
it is to process them and send them into
the interior within 72 hours that is
their plan
and then they wonder why there is a
search at the border of course there's a
search at the border you're literally
saying to people if you show up here
within 72 hours you're just in the
united states
and we know that there's no real way to
date these people and we know
that the biden administration wants to
amnesty all of them of course you're
going to get a massive surge at the
border
they're creating the crisis the crisis
is biden created
russell hot and a senior official with
ice notified staff of the rapid
processing plan in an email on thursday
it said arrivals by unaccompanied minors
and families this year are expected to
be the highest numbers observed
in 20 years 20 years not a crisis
just a challenge and not even really a
challenge we know what to do here which
is to apparently just release people
into the interior
don't worry guys it is it is not
actually it is not actually
a a crisis that requires them to do
anything in fact it is a
massive transformational change to the
immigration system that is what we are
actually watching
according to the washington post itself
transforming family detention
amounts to a wholesale repudiation not
only of donald trump's policy but also
barack obama's
remember obama actually deported a lot
of people it presents a significantly
different vision of how to handle the
fast-changing character
of mass migration at the southern border
for decades
single adults dominated the flows
northward into the united states the
number of families and minors
has increased substantially before the
code pandemic migrant families and
unaccompanied minors were a majority of
those taken into custody at the
southwest
border during the obama and trump
administration families were released or
deported but some were held in dormitory
style facilities for weeks or months
now they're basically just going to
release everybody
so you wonder why there's a crisis it is
because it has been created by the biden
administration don't worry guys
it's open biden open open borders open
biden that's all this is
because biden's moderate of course not
only is biden and moderate biden knows
what's best for you
see the way that open biden works is
that if he declares that something is
not a crisis it's not a crisis
and if it declares that something is a
crisis then it requires instant action
this moment in accordance with his
greatest wishes so when we have
thousands of people just entering the
united states willy-nilly
that's not a crisis so we should just
release them into the interior
if however we have a coveted pandemic
that is clearly on the wane
if we have vaccines that are being put
into arms at the rate of 2 million a day
if we have all of that if the case load
in the united states is now at lowe's we
have not seen for months
and has been dropping precipitously if
all of that that's still a crisis
because it's a useful crisis
make no mistake for democrats the only
question about a situation and whether
it is a crisis or not
is whether it is useful to their
political agenda and right now covet is
useful to the political agenda by the
way not just of the biden administration
but useful to members of the media
and one of the more shocking admissions
recently the ceo
of warner media which is the parent
company of cnn
a person named jason killer he was at a
virtual tech conference on thursday
and he actually said he actually said
out loud that the pandemic is a great
thing
for the news cycle which
by the way is the same remark that
you'll remember jeff zucker originally
made about donald trump in 2016 that he
was great for the news cycle so they
gave him a billion dollars in free media
coverage and made him president
well because the media love kovid so
they're not going to let it go here is
jason killar
saying exactly this essentially if you
take a look at the the ratings and the
performance
it's going well and i think it's going
well because a the team at cnn is doing
a fantastic job
and b it turns out that the pandemic and
the way that we can help inform and
contextualize
them pandemic um it turns out it's
really good for ratings
um and uh and then later he came out he
was like i wish i could be more
thoughtful about my communication but
here's the thing
we all know we all know that the media
have a very large stake
in the continuation of crisis pandemic
coverage
they do because they don't want to cover
biden as a crisis they don't want to
cover the biden administration is doing
anything radical
right they don't want people to know
about that what they do want is to
mirror the priorities of the democratic
party and the priorities of the
democratic party right now are to treat
immigration as a non-crisis and to treat
kovid as a massive crisis despite the
fact
that what was a crisis even three months
ago is not a crisis now okay covet is no
longer a crisis in the united states our
icu beds are not being threatened
the people are are not getting this at
the same rate
we are reaching hurt immunity just as
marty mccary of johns hopkins university
suggested but again crisis is an
opportunity
so what does that mean for the biden
administration for the bible
administration what that means
is that anybody who attempts to end the
crisis is a bad guy which is why the
other day you heard
joe biden stumble out there and suggest
between bites of oatmeal that the that
those who wanted to reopen states
and get rid of mass mandates were
neanderthals it was neanderthal thinking
it was neanderthal thinking yes freedom
is neanderthal thinking
you and your ability to choose what to
do as an individual that's neanderthal
thinking
the galaxy brains out there the ones who
have been saying for months and months
and months that lockdowns were the only
sure policy
and the ones who say right now that
schools cannot reopen those galaxy
brains
they should rule but you the individual
deciding how you wish to live your life
what risk you wish to undergo you you
are neanderthal
babylon be had a great headline about
this neanderthals out partying
while civilized people hide in caves
that's pretty much right
hey so how much by the way do the
members of the biden administration
sustain the american public and their
ability to make decisions for themselves
how much do they think that the people
of the united states really ought not
rule themselves
a lot the the fundamental distinction
between left and right in the united
states right now
is that the left loves the people
collectively but hates individual
decision making
and they love the people because they
believe that they can mobilize the mob
to do whatever they want which
seemingly is true a lot of the time on
the right
we're kind of scared of them up because
the mob usually has terrible ideas but
we like individuals in which they would
make their own decisions
okay so here is jen sackey to writing
individuals making their own decisions
in fact
she was asked specifically by a reporter
whether biden's neanderthal comments
went far enough
and she basically agreed that they
didn't go far enough that basically if
you are an individual
who wants to go out and live your life
after you've been vaccinated for example
or you're not that afraid to covet or
you're not dealing with people who are
vulnerable
if you're one of those people then
you're a lizard brain you're a dum-dum
here's here is jen sackey white house
press secretary basically deriding a
huge
number of americans why doesn't the
president
consider ratcheting up his rhetoric
beyond neanderthal
and personalizing his concern why
doesn't for example
why doesn't he think about saying folks
here's the deal you don't wear your mask
people are going to die because of you
that would certainly get people's
attention
we'll note it i will say the president
has been clear
that if people wear masks for a hundred
days
sixty thousand lives could be saved i
mean it's just unbelievable so she's
she's go what we really need is to scare
people and tell them that they're
killing people because they haven't
heard that from the media
for months they haven't heard it at all
it's a brand new idea then jen sackey
specifically defended the neanderthal
comment with a with a tactic that you
should never use in a personal
relationship here is jen sackey
on biden's neanderthal comments
specifically
does the president have any second
thoughts about the language that he used
yesterday and
how does comparing someone to a
neanderthal help convince them to change
course and get on board with your public
health message
the behavior of a neanderthal just to be
very clear
the behavior of look i think the
president what we what everybody saw
yesterday was a reflection of
his frustration and exasperation which i
think many
american people have that for almost a
year now
uh people across the country have
sacrificed okay i mean it's just
it's unreal and uh that is a horrible
tactic in a personal relationship
so note dudes if you're if you're dating
a lady
and you say you're acting like a
and she says
did you just call me a and you say
no no i said you're acting like a
that's not gonna work that's not gonna
work because it's unbelievably stupid
jen sackey just said that about about
the american people no he didn't call
you in neanderthal he said you're acting
like a neanderthal
oh that's so much better thank you jen
we all feel better now
hey come on come on but this is what
they think of you
they think you are unable to make your
own decisions because again the entire
left world view
is dependent on the idea that people are
the creation of systems so if people
make their own decisions and those
decisions are bad it's because the
system is bad
and that means that we have to change
the system and the only way to change
the system is with top down control
top down control is the only answer
always and forever and as the pandemic
wanes the media
who are just the pr wing of the
democratic party will not let it wane
they will not let it happen
the new york times has a piece today
titled plan to ditch the mask after
vaccination
not so fast
here is the case they make with 50
million americans at least partly
immunized against the coronavirus and
millions more joining the ranks every
day
the urgent question on many minds is
when can i throw away my mask it's a
deeper question than it seems about a
return to normalcy about how soon
vaccinated americans can hug loved ones
get together with friends go to concerts
shopping malls restaurants without
feeling threatened by covid
certainly many state officials already
on tuesday texas lifted its mass mandate
along with mississippi but the pandemic
is not over yet and scientists are
counseling
patients ooh the science test science it
seems clear
small groups of vaccinated people can
get together without much worry about
infecting one another
okay so um quick note why small why not
large
any any ideas here if you're vaccinated
what's the problem the answer is there
really isn't one but they're still
pushing it
when vaccinated people can ditch the
masks in public spaces will depend on
how quickly the rates of disease drop
and what percentage of people remain
unvaccinated in the surrounding
community
why scientists do not know whether
vaccinated people spread the virus to
those who are unvaccinated
well actually we do have some early data
and the answer is they really don't
okay again the early data demonstrate
that the transmission rates from people
who are vaccinated is extremely low
extremely low but
we have to hide this from the american
public so we can scare them into staying
in their houses so we can pass 1.9
trillion dollar
pork bills that do all the priority work
that democrats are looking for it to do
and we have to keep the schools close so
we can keep paying off the teachers
unions
and we have to push all the left-wing
priorities by suggesting that americans
are bad and stupid and neanderthals
they say it's not uncommon for a vaccine
to force all severe disease but not
infection
inoculations against the flu rotavirus
polio pertussis are all imperfect
in this way i mean that's true but you
know what pertussis
is out there my daughter actually got
pertussis after having the vaccine
and that does happen pertussis weakens
the symptoms produces vaccine weakens
the symptoms
of pertussis okay does that mean that we
all started wearing masks like
all the time the answer of course is no
and now coronavirus variants that dodge
the immune system are changing the
calculus some vaccines are less
effective
at preventing infections with certain
variants in theory they could allow more
viruses yeah a lot of theory here
a lot of theory but guess what people
are not going to keep living this way
especially because what we're going to
do this for another year we're just
going to do this interminably
for disease that at its worst on average
in america killed five people per
thousand who actually got it
disproportionately people who are
elderly in nursing homes and we can make
special protections for and special
provisions for
the answer is no the answer is no but
again there's an agenda here
and the agenda is that we are never
gonna give up control once people have
control they don't want to give up
the control and it is amazing to watch
because
the reality is this should not be it
really is not a red blue thing
there's one state that people on the
left are completely ignoring these days
by the way it is a state that just
reopened
hey you know what state just reopened
are you ready for this
the state is wait for it connecticut
deep red connecticut is now reopening as
well
according to the hartford quran governor
ned lamont on thursday announced he will
roll back coveted related restrictions
in connecticut starting march 19th
allowing restaurants to operate at full
capacity
loosening rules on sports and
entertainment venues lifting the state's
travel ban
the state will maintain some key
measures like a mass mandate oh well you
know if it's gonna mouse mandate
social distancing rules a curfew for
restaurants and closure of bars
restaurants retail stores houses of
worship other businesses will be allowed
to reopen at full capacity within the
confines of the remaining rules okay by
the way if you reopen
uh if you reopen a church at full
capacity or a restaurant at full
capacity
without and the mass mandate's still in
place and restaurants people aren't
going to wear the masks
everybody knows what this is so
connecticut is doing the same thing
effectively speaking the texas and
mississippi are doing they're just lying
about it by saying that they have a mask
mandate
you can't have a mask mandated at a
restaurant people are eating and
drinking so if you open the restaurants
to full capacity
indoors effectively speaking the
pandemic's over i mean that is what you
are saying
but it's a blue state so we're just
going to ignore that texas mississippi
floor those are the bad ones
of course we're going to get to the most
vaunted of all doctors
dr anthony fauci we're going to get to
dr fauci who
is loving this loving it
we're going to get to that in one second
first let us talk about something great
that you can do
for yourself for your family i'm talking
of course about preserving your family
memories now
my baby daughter she just had her first
birthday and we're lucky she grew up in
the era of digital media so we have
all of her videos and her and her photos
available to us very quickly but
what about all the old photos and videos
you have of your family from your
childhood or from your parents childhood
what about all that stuff that stuff is
just out in the garage and it is falling
apart
you need to get it preserved legacy box
is the way to do it
legacy box makes the process really easy
from start to finish you pack
you send their team digitizes everything
by hand and then you enjoy you get back
perfectly preserved digital copies on a
thumb drive dvd or the cloud
ready to watch and share and enjoy
they've thought of everything they even
provide state-of-the-art tracking send
you updates at every step of the process
you can send your precious recorded
moments to a company you can trust i
know the people who founded legacy box
nick and adam really solid dudes they
started this company over a decade ago
today
over 850 000 families have trusted them
to digitally preserve their past we did
it ourselves
i got my parents old film reels
transferred over it's amazing it's
amazing to watch get started preserving
your past today go to legacybox.com
shapiro to get an incredible 40 off your
first order buy today take advantage of
this exclusive offer
send in when you are ready go to
legacybox.com
shapiro save 40 while supplies last
again go to legacybox.com
shapiro save 40 while supplies last okay
in just a second we're gonna get to the
greatest doctor of all time dr anthony
fauci
but first it is that glorious time of
the week when i give a shout out to a
daily wire member today
it is courtrageous eight on instagram
who perfectly captures what we're all
thinking this week
in this picture two examples of the
world's greatest beverage sit
atop a large stack of dr seuss books
with more of his products placed around
the table the caption reads
i can't wait to catch all the leftist
years as i read dr seuss's greatest
works
hashtag leftist tears tumblers hashtag
can't cancel the goats
well done your tumblers will indeed be
overflowing thank you for the picture
for being a daily ware member and for
standing up against the cancellation of
doctors who's honestly
our society is so screwed and stupid
earlier this week i had the pleasure of
discussing minimum wage
on my radio show with representative
rokhana it is very refreshing to talk
with people outside
of your political safe space and what do
we talk about
we talk about minimum wage well here's
the thing i thought that that
discussion was interesting and i thought
that frankly uh the points made
on minimum wage by by representative
khanna were not particularly convincing
i thought that because i know the facts
and here's the thing you can know the
facts too
all you have to do is check out our new
series debunked in debunked every week i
break down a new lefty myth
a new lefty idea we break it down based
on facts and logic
last week we dropped an episode on
minimum wage
so you would know a lot about minimum
wage you'd be able to fight that one out
on social media with your friends you'd
be able to stand up for your own point
of view
this week we are breaking down public
sector unions why they are dangerous why
are there a problem particularly
particularly those teachers unions that
joe biden loves so much
if you want to get the simple facts and
logic the debunk left his claims on
these issues
tune in debunked is available
exclusively to daily wire members head
on over to dailywire.com
subscribe use code debunked to get 25
off your new membership that is code
debunked you're listening to the largest
fastest growing conservative podcast and
radio show in the nation
so quick note here the united states
this last month
added back 379 000 jobs 379 000 jobs
but remember it's still a crisis we're
still in the middle of a crisis right we
need more spending we need to blow out
the spending
more fed spending can't open the schools
crisis crisis crisis and that is the
message from the biden administration
and the best doctor of all time except
for dr joe biden who's the greatest
medical doctor i've ever seen
i single-handedly watched as dr jill
biden
took a man who was clinically dead and
sent him to a junior college
okay dr joel biden is unbelievable at
what she does
anyway dr fauci who's the second best
doctor dr anthony fauci
he uh he is now out there again down
talking
the possible reopening of american
society suggesting
that we can never reopen effectively
speaking here he was on cnn doing his
routine
the song and dance saying i don't know
why we're easing restrictions
until we're below 10 000 cases per day
we can't do it
maybe zero maybe negative maybe we'll
have to go back in time and kill people
for us to reopen back to anthony falchi
i wouldn't want to see a light switch go
on and off with regard to restrictions
jake
i would like to see as we get the level
of virus
in the community to a very low level
well well
below the 60 to 70 000 new infections
somewhere you know i'll
just pick a number even though you know
there's not a good model there yet but i
would say
less than 10 000 and maybe even
considerably less than that
i mean let's get it all the way down to
zero i mean that's that's what we should
do
and if we don't do that we can never
reopen so we're never opening and then i
can be on tv every single day
and they'll give me prizes and they'll
talk about how important i am and people
will
light food with candles to me and um
people will call me sexy
even though i'm alie it's weird i mean
like why are we listening to him
i i just don't know honestly he's a
horrible advocate for his own position
he down talked the eff the efficacy of
vaccines he lied about the herd immunity
numbers he lied about masking
and why is that guy still and the answer
is that
any tool for the for the crisis as
progress mentality is a tool worth using
so fancy is now saying it's inexplicable
why do you want is it inexplicable
though
really question is it inexplicable
because i can explain it
seriously it's actually quite explicable
all i have to do is look at the numbers
i will bring them up right now
okay the reason that it is explicable to
reopen right now is because the daily
new cases
as of early january were or 280 300
000 on january 8th 308 000 diagnosed
cases
of cover 19 on january 8th today we are
down to about 40
000 new cases a day and um and so
i i did i just explained it i feel like
i explained it i have another number
that would explain it
icu capacity was uh was being challenged
in january
right now there's not an icu department
in america that is being challenged by
covet
so um that was explicable and in fact i
just did it in
inside of like 10 seconds isn't that
amazing but it's inexplicable why you'd
want to pull back now says anthony fauci
it just is inexplicable why you would
want to pull back now i understand
the need to want to get back to
normality
but you're only going to set yourself
back if you just completely pull
push aside the public health guidelines
particularly
when we're dealing with anywhere from 55
to 70
000 infections per day in the united
states that's a very
very high baseline okay so again this is
like
at this point the reason that they don't
want to reopen is because they don't
want individuals to have free choice end
of story
they also don't want schools to reopen
so fauci who's been on every side of
this position again he's had more
positions on school reopening than the
kama sutra recommends as i've said
before
he says that now schools need to change
their ventilation systems before opening
okay well anything else anything else
bobo like seriously what
like how many more things can you just
throw out there
we can't reopen until we have full
ultraviolet lighting systems in all of
america's schools
even though the data is that the school
should be open like right now in full
with kids there here is fouchy
we've got to make sure that the schools
have the resources to do the kinds of
things they need to do
which would be making sure they have
masks and ppe
making sure that the ventilation system
can be improved to be able to
diminish the likelihood that they'll be
spread of infection
there you know the cdc guidelines are
pretty
explicit it's a detailed guidelines
about what you can do
the kinds of things you can do the steps
the masking the distancing the kinds of
things
that we know can help protect the
children and
the teachers okay whatever i mean
honestly whatever these are the same
people who are touting andrew cuomo
while he lied for months
the same i mean fauci said that cuomo's
response was like the ideal response
speaking of which new report from the
wall street journal now verified by the
new york times
andrew cuomo's aides rewrote nursing
home reports to hide the higher death
total
so right now they're trying to oust him
in new york supposedly based on the
sexual harassment stuff it has nothing
to do with that he's just embarrassing
to them and they're finding a different
reason to take him out back and cap him
it's that simple they want to bury him
in a shallow grave in iowa and fill it
in
while he's still breathing and the
reason that he really has to do that the
reason they have to do that to him is
because of his coveted policy but they
can never admit
that it was his covet policy because
that would be admitting that it was
their coveted policy that was bad
the reality is that andrew cuomo
shouldn't just be not in office he might
need to be in jail for his actual
activity during covid
but they touted him as the anti-trump
they cheered him
and so now they have to look for some
ancillary reason to get rid of the guy
according to the new york times top
aides to governor andrew cuomo were
alarmed
a report written by state health
officials had just landed and it
included accounts of how many nursing
home residents in new york had died in
the pandemic
the number more than 9 000 by that point
in june was not public
when the governor's most senior aides
wanted to keep it that way they rewrote
the report to take it out
according to interviews and documents
reviewed by the new york times
the extraordinary intervention which
came just as cuomo was starting to write
a book
on his pandemic achievements was the
earliest act yet in what critics have
called a months-long effort by the
governor and his aides to obscure the
full scope of nursing home deaths
again this was in june is in june
could you guys do a little digging right
then are you too busy flogging
his his stupid book about his leadership
during covet
and cheering him as a possible nominee
should joe biden fall off
a short chair and die i mean
these people are just absurd the new
york times is absurd all these people
are ridiculous
i'm glad they can report on it in march
of the next year when andrew cuomo
becomes a liability
seriously and they were doing this while
he was writing a book of course he was
doing it while he was writing a book
of course of course meanwhile again the
down talking of the possibility of
reopening continues
on a daily basis it's wild and the
reality is that things are going pretty
well
and one of the reasons things are going
pretty well is because we are now
tranching out vaccines developed under
trump with plans developed by governors
all across the united states really
isn't because of the feds it's because
of the governors
okay and that is going well and the same
administration
that is pushing the idea that there is
inequity in vaccine distribution and
kind of poo pooing
or at least winking and nodding at the
idea that the johnson johnson vaccine
which is a one-shot vaccine that is
slightly less effective than the two
shot vaccines
but it's still pretty damn defective
that if you if you have too many brown
and black people who are getting the
johnson johnson vaccine maybe that is a
sign of systemic inequity
okay the reality is that johnson and
johnson shot just like all these other
shots is essentially a medical miracle
even the new york times acknowledging
that now saying people are eager for
johnson and johnson's vaccine
but again it's all about inequity in the
distribution of the shots
simultaneously the biden administration
is claiming we're doing a great job
with our with our shots and also nobody
deserves credit for the vaccine
see rachelle willenski over at the cdc
saying we are on track with these
vaccines and trenching them out we're
doing an amazing job and then you have
jen
sackey over at the white house saying
you know what
i don't think we should give the trump
team any credit for the vaccine nobody
deserves credit for the vaccine
says that jen sackey i don't think
anyone deserves credit when half a
million
people in the country have died of this
pandemic so
what our focus is on and when the
president's focus is on when he came
into office just over a month ago
was ensuring that we had enough vaccines
we have that we are going to have them
now we had enough vaccinators
and we had enough vaccine locations to
get this pandemic under control
uh there's no question and all data
points to the fact that there were not
enough of
any of those things when he took office
and and so he is the magi man so
biden deserves credit for everything but
the development of the vaccine no one
deserves credit for that because a lot
of people died
really well done there gen sackey and by
the way this this crisis mentality the
continuation of the crisis mentality so
the democrats can continue to push
forward bad policy
that is on every single front it's on
every single front it's not a crisis if
it's immigration
it is a crisis if it's covet and by the
way it's also a crisis
if you once heard a rumor from a guy on
8chan
about how there was like a boogaloo
thing happening on march 4th
so now we are learning that nancy pelosi
and the capitol police
are asking are demanding more fencing
more troops and more money for capital
security they want to keep the troops
there another
two months two months this is crazy
towns
yeah january 6th was an act of evil also
it would have been stymied by
a few more troops there the response
from nancy pelosi and the democrats is
perfectly political it is we are going
to keep troops here pretty much forever
we are going to keep this barbed wire
here as an immortal monument
to the evils of president trump and the
people who supported him i mean nancy
pelosi is basically just saying that
nancy pelosi came out yesterday she said
we have to keep these fences here and
the barbed wire and you know it looks as
though we're in a third world country
now and we have troops here like all the
time sleeping on the grounds and
sure they're not properly fed or kept
but you know we need them here we need
yesterday no one showed up march 4th was
supposed to be
another one of these magical riot days
it didn't happen nothing like zero zip
zilch
no one showed up and nancy pelosi's like
well we gotta keep these people here
pretty much forever as a reminder as an
eternal reminder
that trump supporters are bad between
covet where we need
to have vaccinations more broadly in the
capital so that many more people
can come here and do their jobs
and uh the threat of um
of all the president's men out there uh
we have to we have to ensure
with our security uh that we are
safe enough to do our job all the
president's men out there impeding
all the president's men out there you
know who's out there yesterday no one no
one
washington post today quote at the
capitol a march 4 threat from militant
trump supporters proves a mirage
oh who could have predicted such a thing
on the day when former president donald
trump's most delusional supporters swore
who returned to power washington looked
on thursday morning much the way it has
for the past two months
national guard members armed with m4
rifles braced for rebellion that never
came
razor wire lined miles of steel fencing
that went unbreached
trump remained in florida where it was
70 degrees and sunny it was nice down
here yesterday actually it's beautiful
weather the angst stems from another
misguided belief within q and on
the extremist ideology that claims trump
has been working in secret to overthrow
a cabal of blood-drinking
satan-worshiping democratic pedophiles
after repeated unfulfilled prophecies
the group's supporters declared in
recent weeks that trump would retake
office
on march 4th okay now here is the thing
what is the good evidence that they were
going to actually do anything yesterday
like at some point it would be nice to
see some of that evidence considering
we're now spending
millions and millions of dollars to keep
troops there and make sure that
that they never leave apparently like
and now apparently amazingly enough
they've decided in the media that the
next state that we have to worry about
is march 20th
where are they getting the information
that we have to worry about march 20th
i'm not kidding you from a guy named
ken not kidding according to
newsweek quote some q anon supporters
seem to rebrand the march 4th conspiracy
in the wake of community suspicion
while two individuals affiliated with
the false theory simply suggested
trump's inauguration would take place
sometime in the spring
one man identified as ken told
washington post reporter dave weigle the
former president
will be inaugurated again on march 20th
well i mean if ken says so
i guess we have to spend hundreds of
millions of i guess we have to spend
millions of dollars not hundreds of
millions we've spent millions of dollars
keeping
thousands of troops in washington d.c
because of ken because ken said so
no this is not at all political at all
we're just gonna keep them there
interminably as a reminder that all the
president's men
might be out there they might be out
there waiting and watching
all of this is um a little over the top
if you have not noticed
okay meanwhile the the
book burning continues anew it continues
each and every day
honestly this story is in some ways even
scarier than the story about the the dr
seuss estate pulling six of his books
including classics like
uh and i and i saw it on mulberry street
and and if i ran the zoo
when they pull those books that is
terrible and awful and it is
self-censorship of an extraordinary
order
it is it is a willingness to cave in the
face
of a woke sensorious authoritarian left
and it degrades our culture it degrades
our freedoms it is bad
okay it is a i don't know when it became
a controversial thing to say that
self-censorship of classic children's
literature is bad
but it's bad but it's now gone even
further than this
ebay is now taking down your ability to
even list these books
so you said to yourself listen i had an
extra copy if i ran the zoo
and now those things are selling for
like 650 bucks because when you make
things samistat when you ban material
like they did in the soviet union
it turns out that people are going to
try and get a hold of the material
when that happens the prices skyrocket
so a lot of people went to ebay to sell
this stuff
now ebay has decided that they are going
to remove the dr seuss books
you cannot as a third party sell these
doctors whose books
now ebay is another one of these neutral
service providers right
ebay is supposed to be like amazon was
supposed to be a neutral service
provider right they don't have an
editorial point of view
and in fact if you looked at ebay
yesterday you could still buy copies of
protocols of the elder's design
you could buy which is eight which is an
anti-semitic conspiracy theory first
created
in cyrus russia you could still buy
copies of mine comp
those were available at decent prices
you couldn't buy copies however if i ran
the zoo
according to newsweek following dr seuss
enterprise's recent decision to
discontinue publishing and licensing
on six of the famous children's authors
books because of problematic content
demand for the titles in question spiked
but even though the resale market for
the controversial seuss books has been
strong
ebay has started to remove listings for
the titles citing its policy on
offensive material
this writer actually has access to a
worn copy of one of the out-of-print
books and to think that i saw it on
mulberry street and listed it on ebay
late tuesday afternoon
on thursday morning this writer received
an email from ebay
saying the listing was removed for
violating an offensive material policy
the automated email said quote listings
that promote or glorify
hatred violence or discrimination aren't
allowed doctors whose enterprises have
stopped publication of this book
due to its negative portrayal of some
ethnicities as a courtesy we have ended
your item and refunded your selling fees
and as long as you do not really list
the item there will be no negative
impact to your account so in other words
they're going to punish you
for having listed a book you did not
write and that you do not agree is a
racist book
they're going to punish you if you
refuse to abide by their strictures
so that now ebay is in on the act
in its email on thursday ebay included
the fine prints of its policy one
portion of the message
which gives an overview of the policy
reads quote items including figurines
cartoons housewares historical
advertisements
historical advertisements and gollywogs
with racist anti-semitic or otherwise
meaning portrayals for example through
caricatures or other exaggerated
features
an ebay spokesperson clarified the
company's position further at ebay we
have a strict policy against hate and
discrimination to ensure our platform
remains a safe trusted and inclusive
environment for our global community of
buyers and sellers
please see our offensive policies
material we're currently sweeping our
marketplace to remove
those items in absolute absurdity so
i guess that hug finn is next can't list
your second-hand copy of huck finn
cause i mean huck finn has the n-word in
it it does just a reality
and as we know from the new york times
anything that has the n-word in it is
bad
unless it's written by nicole hannah
jones in which case it is good
so ebay has now removed your ability to
even sell second-hand
dr seuss books when neutral platforms
neutral service providers
become the tools of the woke in their
sensorious attempts
to remove and erase history and removing
a race by the way non-offensive
children's books there's not a single
human being
who until the woke got a hold of it ever
looked at if i ran the zoo and said wow
this is so brutally offensive i can't
believe it
or mulberry street which is even less
controversial
it's amazing by the way what is on the
near reading list according to jared
stepman over at the daily signal what's
on the near reading list
well if you're a kid you can't read and
to think that i saw it on mulberry
street which i read my books
i read to my kids yesterday i did it
just to show them just to show them i
felt a little
the sort of thrill of disregard for the
woke
when i read mulberry street this is how
stupid everything has become
what books does the na recommend you
read you can't read to your kids
about an imaginary parade in which a
chinese person carries chopsticks you
cannot read that that is terribly bad
but you should and it is recommended by
the nea the national education
association
that you read to your children julian is
a mermaid about a little boy who sees
women dressed as mermaids and wants to
dress like them
also the prince in the dressmaker about
a prince who secretly wears dresses at
night they recommend you read this
not you're allowed to they recommend it
it is recommended by the nea
there's also americanized rebel without
a green card about an illegal immigrant
from iran there's also we are here to
stay
voices of undocumented young adults also
about illegal immigration
there is also stamped racism anti-racism
racism and you
oh it is from ibrahmex kendi so overt
bizarre racist ibrahmax kenzie that guy
they recommend his books by the way
speaking of imax kenny
uh ever max kennedy is such an
unbelievable ridiculous backwards racist
that he actually tweeted this out
yesterday and this is this is
the kafka move right here the heartbeat
of racism is denial
and too often the more powerful the
racism the more powerful the denial
the heartbeat of racism is actually
hatred and bigotry
but he doesn't care about hatred and
bigotry he cares about being able to
label anyone he wants racist so if you
deny that you're a racist this makes you
a racist
is why it's called a kafka move right
because
like franz kafka in the trial
you are guilty if you say that you are
innocent and you are guilty if you say
that you are guilty
if if you are a witch then you will
absolutely sink to the bottom of the
river
then you will absolutely float if you're
a wedge if you're a witch you'll float
and if you are not a witch you will sink
that's how we'll find out whether you're
witch or not
so that guy wrote a crappy children's
book and we are going to
use that as the basis for teaching
children we're going to actively teach
children about racial essentialism
but if they see a cartoon picture
of asian people carrying a mythical
animal
in a book about a child running a zoo
then obviously that is going to create
all sorts of racist sentiment
amazing stuff really solid stuff here
from um from our culture our culture is
doing a great job
and it's going to extend to movies now
long piece in the hollywood reporter by
rebecca keegan today
racist sexist classic how hollywood is
dealing with its problematic content
as streamers build out their lucrative
libraries they're experimenting with
label warnings
context panels and even purges these are
valuable properties you cannot just
disregard you want to keep them but you
have to make sure they don't damage the
brand
they say every month disney convenes an
eclectic group of advisors via video
conference to tell the media
conglomerate what it may
what it and the many entertainment
companies it has acquired over its
nearly 100 year history have gotten
wrong
every single month they're doing these
struggle sessions it's a long list
song of the south jar jar binks
i mean jar jar binks is wrong but i
don't know why why is
jar jar problematic i mean i understand
that
he's a terrible character but we're
cancelling charge right now
i mean first of all and i i i will say
that anybody who caps jar jar
is a hero to me but if the world capped
jar jar
that seems like they're on the dark side
that episode of the muppet show where
johnny cash sings a duet with miss piggy
in front of a confederate flag
yeah very you know how many people were
radicalized by that you know how many
people became white supremacist because
they saw
johnny cash singing duet with miss piggy
in front of a confederate flag
so many people joined the kkk because of
that we've had some raw conversation on
these zooms
says gil robertson president of the
african-american film critics
association who sits on disney's
advisory council
alongside representatives from groups
like the coalition of asian pacifics and
entertainment and the gina davis
institute on gender in media as well as
representatives from various departments
at disney including programming
public policy diversity and inclusion
disney asks robertson and his colleagues
to watch content that may contain
stereotypes or insensitive imagery and
offer their perspectives
here's the thing you are now outsourcing
your wokeness to these groups these
groups only survive by finding things to
be offended by
you know what happened to these groups
if there were nothing offensive or if
they actually
reported the truth which is that they
are not offended by any of this stuff
you know what happened to them
no one would need them they're not going
to unwoke themselves
out of a job when disney hands over
power to all of these interest groups
what they are doing is saying to them
you now have an incentive to call things
racist
so that we have to keep coming back to
you for our latest re-up
so now they're they're trying to reframe
classic films on tcm
ccm host ben mann quite says nobody's
cancelling these movies our job is not
to get up and say here's a movie you
should feel guilty about for liking
but to pretend the racism in it is not
painful and acute no i don't want to shy
away from that
this was inevitable and welcomed and
overdue
or we could you know just let people
make their own decisions about things
i know terrible terrible idea so
tropic thunder i guess is bad it's very
it's offensive tropic thunder now
robert downey jr got a best supporting
actor nomination for that by the way
older shows and movies are still big
business as the hollywood reporter on
disney plus
nearly 80 of the tv demand was for these
streaming services licensed in library
shows
only about 20 was for original shows
like the mandalorian which also have to
be wiped clean by the way
of anyone who thinks differently as we
learned about gina carano
in 2019 miramax's 700 film library was
valued at 750 million dollars
the libraries at disney and warner media
are multi-billion dollar assets
but the need for studios to reckon with
their racist histories took on a new
urgency last summer as black lives
matter protests were unfolding no no
they didn't actually
they seriously did not nobody cared
about this
nobody was clamoring for it you just
decided to do it preemptively because
the woke control your companies
and because you know that the woke are
loud and squeaky and they bother you
so now they're going to contextualize
everything or maybe even remove it
maybe even remove it
drawing attention to problems in their
own archives does carry risk for studios
kermit cancelled asked a headline on the
conservative website the daily wire when
disney rolled out disclaimers on 18
episodes of the muppet show
when the host of fox and friends asked
arkansas senator tom cotton about
disclaimers on february
24th the lawmaker brought up the
studio's relationship with china
yeah that's that is correct these types
of canceled culture critiques have not
deterred the studios
no of course they haven't why would they
because here's the thing they have a
monopoly on the entertainment properties
they can always just remove it and
that's what eventually will happen
if you think that the content warnings
are going to be enough they won't
eventually the woke are going to demand
that these things just go away
permanently because they're harmful
and no matter how many times you warn
people about context trigger warnings
aren't enough
they have to be removed and unlike in
the real world
where you know gina carano can get fired
by disney and we can pick her up
if i could buy the rights to if i ran
the zoo and just sell it via daily wire
i absolutely would but i can't because
dr seuss enterprises is taking it down
and they own the right
same thing is going to happen at disney
they're just going to take down
intellectual property and bury it and
kill it
and the world will become a less
interesting and fun and eclectic place
because this is what cancel this is what
cancellation does this is what
censorship does
even stuff you disagree with i know
there's a hard thought for the same
people who used to believe in the aclu
but even the aclu no longer believes
in the aclu and here's the thing there
is no end to it
like no end to it michael strahan
good example and no matter how much you
apologize it will never be enough disney
can put the context warnings tstcm can
do this
this new contextualizing series they can
do all that stuff it won't make one iota
of difference because in the end
there is no end right so here's the
thing about religion
religion when you repent before god god
accepts it the woke when you repent
before the woke they murder you
they kill your career they destroy your
life chris harrison who's the host of
the bachelor or was
and now has been deemed unfit to be the
host of a of a silly dating show
because he had the temerity to suggest
that a woman ought to be given grace for
going to an antebellum
antebellum themed party in 2018 after
her black boyfriend on the show
suggested she'd be given grace
he's been canceled he went on good
morning america and he apologized for
himself
he said that he was he was
insufficiently sensitive and all this
this created the impetus for michael
strahan to now declare that
he was not sufficiently sincere his
sincerity was not good enough
and so he must remain cancelled here's
michael strahan
his apology is his apology but it felt
like it got nothing more than a surface
response on any of this and obviously he
the men who want to
clearly stay on the show but only time
will tell if there is any meaning
behind his words only time will tell but
there's no way for him to prove it
because you're not going to let him back
on the show
because you don't want it back on the
show our culture has shown its neck to
the woke and the woke
are just cutting it off i mean that's
that is all that is happening here
so how do you fight back against it well
first of all make your voices heard make
it clear to disney
that if they begin to cancel shows that
you like you're not going to take your
money there
find alternatives create new projects
and that's what we're doing here at
dailywire and we need your help this is
why i recommend it to everybody get a
membership at dailywire we are pushing
into the culture war because culture is
upstream of politics
but recognize that what the left does
right now their greatest trick
is that they will take a seminal piece
of literature like dr seuss they'll
cancel it and then they'll say why are
you even paying attention
you also be paying attention because
these are indicators of a culture that
is in complete
collapse the only way to shore it up is
to stand up for the culture even stuff
you disagree with
already we will be back here later today
with an additional hour of content first
you cannot forget to end your week by
checking out the andrew clavin show drew
show is every friday he's got an
exciting evening planned for you so
head on over to dailywire.com this
evening at 7 pm eastern and tune in i'm
ben shapiro this is the ben shapiro show
the ben shapiro show is produced by
elliott feld executive producer jeremy
borin
our supervising producer is mathis
glover and our assistant director is
pavo wiedowsky
editing is by psy events audio is mixed
by mike coromina
hair and makeup is by fabiola christina
production assistant is jessica crans
the ben shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2021
hey everybody this is andrew clavin host
of the andrew clavin show
you know some people are depressed
because the republic is collapsing the
end of days is approaching and the moons
turn to blood
but on the andrew clavin show that's
where the fun just gets started so come
on over to the andrew clavin show and
laugh your way through the fall of the
republic
with me andrew clavin